[Musique]
bonjour nous poursuivons notre série
d'entretiens dans le cadre des
municipales après les candidats nous
recevrons dans son caddie les
représentants du monde économique social
culturel et sportif a fait qu'elle
puisse nous dire nous expliquer ce
qu'ils peuvent attendre de ces élections
municipales et communautaires bonjour
olivier marie reine bonjour bonjour des
antilles alors vous êtes le président du
comité des pêches
avant d'aborder vos doléances pour ces
élections traceur d'abord le bilan de la
profession 700 marins pêcheurs chiffre
en baisse
vous étiez me lie à un millier il ya
quelques années
pourquoi comment vous expliquer cette
baisse cette diminution or déjà rouleau
compresseur du chlordécone est
énormément de collègues qui ont été
injectés de leur profession à cause du
chlordécone c'est devenu beaucoup plus
peiné pour eux d'aller plus loin dans
des endroits aussi demander d'efforts
beaucoup d'efforts dallas ou aller dans
une ordonnance doit stressant et ils
n'ont pas pu tenir le rythme et c'était
en trésorerie beaucoup trop lourd pour
eux et site et lisses et peau continent
rien donné d'accord la wla prix la
profession était sinistrée avec cette
histoire de chlordécone ah oui c'est un
des maillons les plus sinistrées en
termes économiques c'est la pêche
d'accord qu'est ce qui a encore provoqué
cette baisse devrait d'après vous c'est
le ça fait un moment qu'ils avaient pas
de subvention en terme de si vous voulez
faire l'acquisition de bateaux neufs
donc les jeunes qui voulaient
s'installer en ont peu souffert de de
cette absence de trésorerie de
subventions aujourd'hui on est en train
de travailler sur le revenu
renouvellement de la flotte de pêche
dans les dom donc probablement qu'en fin
d'année
tu vois des subventions pour
l'acquisition de matériel de pêche 9
tels que bateaux et autres
est ce que la profession justement se
renouvelle on sait que alors on va rire
on a une école de pêche
à trinité mais ce que la profession se
renouvelle ya très peu de renouvellement
en donnant à voir moins d'une dizaine
d'installations de jeunes marins
pêcheurs par année donc c'est un métier
qui attire alors c'est un beau métier
qui lorsqu'on en pratique on a choisi de
le faire mais aujourd'hui la réalité est
autre
c'est un métier où on vend moins bien sa
vie et c'est pas parce que en termes
d'exploitation
on gère mal non c'est parce qu'il ya un
problème de pollution est allé beaucoup
plus loin coûte plus cher ça use
l'organisme ça use aussi le matériel et
on ya 15 20 ans on n'a pas pu un petit
peu avant cette vision là sur le long
terme
alors vous êtes confrontés à quel type
de problème alors on a parlé du
chlordécone
mais quel type route de problème vous
qu'on construit également les
infrastructures aussi sans vie sans les
machines à glace non elles sont
renouvelées pour renouveler
prochainement
mais aujourd'hui elles ont très mal
vieilli et c'était peut-être mal adapté
à notre situation en martinique des
pêcheurs du fonds soit aux marins ils
vont vauquelin donc dont le lot
quotidien les pêcheurs souffre pour
faire des actes que les autres font de
façon de façon dans leur quotidien sans
problème ailleurs voit donc c'est une
vraie contrainte et c'est une contrainte
journalières c'est à dire vous allez à
la pêche aujourd'hui des fois il vous
fait vous faire 20 km pour avoir de la
glace
le prix de l'essence aussi il est pas
modéré 1
aujourd'hui on les descend c'est aux
alentours de 0 80 90 certaines fois mais
c'est très cher ça représente des fois à
25% du chiffre d'affaires vous êtes
l'essence détaxée et même si c'est
désaxé mais ça reste bon il faut pour
aller faire une sur le dissiper qu'on en
atlantique où des fois en caraïbe faucon
ses pensées une des pensionnaires ya au
moins de 200 euros
certains vont dire veut dépenser 150
d'autres vont aujourd'hui 250 du
phénomène aux alentours de 200 euros la
journée
alors vous parliez du chlordécone on va
on va s'arrêter sur ce point là il ya un
plan chlordécone 4
vous avez fait en élaboration vous avez
fait des propositions dans ce cadre là
alors qu'à taxes qu'on a qu'on appuie
fortement c'est pour une période de 15
ans il faut une exonération totale des
charges bio s'offrir des cg aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on demande à nos collègues
qu'elle handicape d'embauché d'un jeune
par exemple il ya dix mois mais le taux
de charge est trop élevé on n'arrive pas
à payer des charges dues au soft donc si
on veut embaucher des jeunes et qu'ils
devaient matin faye qui a qui prennent
la relève
ben écoutez il faut qu un autre et loïc
nous permettre de payer les charges
l'handicap on l'a ciblé on a pointé
c'est l'urssaf
aujourd'hui même lorsqu'il ya des
subventions pour la production qu'on
appelle fonds de compensation de 2,6 au
goût si vous n'êtes pas à jour de
l'urssaf
vous pouvez à pas avoir ces subventions
pour la production de 50 énormément de
marins pêcheurs du système donc il faut
attirer les cinq premiers pêcheurs pour
une période de 15 ans deuxièmement le
plan de communication aujourd'hui vous
avez vu votre même groupe sur les
langues ce qui s'est passé en fin
d'année c'est une mauvaise communication
mais pourquoi parce que l'on a laissé un
vide on communique pas suffisamment
aujourd'hui il faut communiquer faut
dire aux gens que nos produits sont
sains que les pêcheurs font des efforts
ils vont pêcher dans des endroits où il
n'y a pas de plan b comme ils vont plus
loin et des fois c'est ce qui fait que
souvent ça mais notre zone très tendue
selon là allait avoir 5 km il faut une
fois la caisse 20 km dont c'est pas le
court le même coup à la 15 km calais à 5
km donc il faut communiquer communiquer
sur 12 ha pour expliquer aux gens que
voici ce qu'on met à disposition de la
clientèle et des produits sains et que
les marins pêcheurs ils sont formés il
faut un vaste plan de communication mais
hyper actif en tout cas deux fois qui ne
sait rien qu'en troisième position
alors aujourd'hui on a vu que les
ouvriers à l'école lorsqu'il ya une loi
qui passait pour la prise en charge
lorsqu'ils au niveau santé il faut point
aussi en compte la santé des marins
pêcheurs
aujourd'hui on veut pts obtenir comme
les ouvriers à l'école dès qu'on a une
suspicion d'une maladie professionnelle
qu'on ait les mêmes propulsé bénéficier
l avis oui exactement
et puis en terme au niveau administratif
il faut aider les marins pêcheurs
aujourd'hui on est sur la touche
numérique beaucoup de marins pêcheurs
maîtrise un peu l'outil numérique mais
n'ont pas le temps donc il faut quand
même une aide administrative
il faudrait une organisation il faut
quand même qu'on fasse on organise ça
peut être le comité aujourd'hui qui aide
les marins pêcheurs dans leur quotidien
a en plus des papiers parce qu'on a une
obligation aujourd'hui à remplir des
papiers chaque fin de mois
si vous êtes mon salarié je dois faire
du patro on n'hésite pas habitué à faire
tous ces trucs là administrativement les
charges de vie et de travail deviennent
explosion donc on est obligé de tenir
compte et une 5e c'est une meilleure
connaissance de la propagation d'une
cour des comptes dans le milieu meilleur
mais la réalité c'est que le niveau de
connaissance il est à 0 tout ce qu'on ne
l'a dit jusqu'à présent ni ride et
approfondie on a bien vu que c'est qu'il
ya eu connaissance aujourd'hui de la
propagation du du chlordécone dans le
milieu marin est très superficiel il
faut approfondir ses connaissances là on
a vu que par les sargasses qu'on a
découvert comme par hasard que si les
sargasses arrivée dans les fonds de bain
en 24 heures dans une fonderie informé
il ya des claude ecken en 24 heures les
sargasses se charger en chlordécone
alors qu'avant nous disait que le
chlordécone cédé dans les sédiments au
fond donc ça veut dire qu'on a vraiment
pas de connaissance et donc il faut un
plan chlordécone mais en termes de
connaissances il faut approfondir les
connaissances alors que comment vous
voyez 7,6 élections municipales et
communautaires
vous faites remonter vos doléances au
maire vous avez déjà reçu des candidats
alors bon jeu ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on avait des pêcheurs un petit peu
partout en vente unique donc chaque
commune à toutes les communautés bichot
les péchés capitaux ghosn a dépêché au
capitou cet esprit et eux ils sont quand
même connecté avec les différents
candidats qui vont aux élections il ya
des pêcheurs sur les listes cette année
vous avez quand même quelques communes
qui ont déjà mis des pêcheurs boulot
bravo quelques soirs je fais pas de
politique de gauche doit rouleau bravo
pour tous les candidats têtes de listes
qui ont pris avec des marins pêcheurs
c'est ce que vous êtes-vous dit marin
pêcheur de s'impliquer de sarcelles
important et pourquoi c'est important et
c'est une valeur ajoutée pour les
futures mères
quand vous avez sur votre liste
un marin pêcheur et dans le volet de la
pêche ou maritime vous avez une
expérience et à côté de vous ça va vous
faire économiser de l'argent et ne pas
faire des conneries tout toute personne
nous a dissipé en pêche expérience aussi
alors que les gens connaissent rien du
tout mais à si vous avez marre des
chocas votre côté qui dans un conseil
municipal il pourra très vite et vous
répondra peut-être du bep à bac il
connaît qui maîtrisent donc ça permet ne
peut-être pas faire trop d'erreurs ou
fait remonter très vite des dossiers qui
quand on les laisse traîner devient de
quoi compliquer je demande à six à douze
pêcheurs et qui ont acquis on a
sollicité voilée sur des lices les gars
alesi cinq ans même importance des
acteurs de la société civile
il faut y aller c'est important c'est la
première fois que ça se produit que
parce qu'on a l'impression que non non
non on sait des pêcheurs ont toujours il
ya toujours eu des pêcheurs sur sur des
jeux des listes mais aujourd'hui suffit
pas d'additionner ces infos est actif
kouassi si vous aller sonner si vous
n'êtes pas actif
ça sert à rien mais bon ici sont je
pense qu'ils sont un actif
il nous reste pas nous reste 20 secondes
une proposition phare qui pourrait être
reprise par 2 par l'abe parlée par les
candidats ce serait laquelle
alors ce qui est important s'il faut pas
s'en contenter des mandats séisme à
abéché non c'est qu'il est venu met à
fouiller audi coyot alès lis même
manière mais un marin pêcheur a coûté
imoca liversay raccourcissement pêcheurs
il faut être à l'écouté
une des revendications coûté il faut
ajouter il faut être à l'écouté c'est ça
qui est important
oui être à l'écouté mais l écoute de
croix se serait cru à la révocation
forte de la profession aujourd'hui
alors pour les meilleurs c'est simple
les maires n'ont presque pas de
compétence sur les ports de pêche
mais bon j'aimerais dire que c'est quand
même le chef de la commune il perdre un
oeil
donc il faut rester vigilant aujourd'hui
on a des collections qui sont sous les
50 pas pour ceux qui sont faut les
protéger
on a des collègues aussi qui
qui ont de grosses difficultés au niveau
social il ya des services aussi au
niveau des mairies
il faut les aider et ça c'est quand même
important donc des revendications pour
les meilleurs cd souvent être à l'école
c'est pas au moment des élections que
les maires doivent venir jouer au grand
quoique messieurs maintenant il faut
être connecté restait souvent aller
olivier marylène je vous remercie
[Musique]